let's take a look at the solution to this its a little bit tricky. Firstly, at
the top of our file we declare two new variables, frameRate and frame. Now,
frameRate represents how often we'd like to actually call the animate function.
Frame is a variable that we're going to use to represent what the current frame
in our flip book is. Since we already have our frames array available, the next
step is to actually loop through our predefined assets, and load each of the
defined images into the frames array. This follows the same 3 step process we
saw before: create a new image, set its on load result, and then set its source.
Once this is done we can actually call this setInterval function, which will
call the animate function at the frameRate that we provided before. Now the
animate function has a little bit of tricky logic inside of it. First off, we
have our frame counter that we've defined. We use this to define what image out
of the frames array we have to draw to the canvas, and of course, at our lovely
position of 192 by 192. Once we've drawn the current frame we actually have to
increment it, and that's where this little nice piece of math comes along. What
we do is increment the frame counter and then modulo it by the frame's length.
What will occur here is that if frame ever becomes longer than frame length, the
modulo function will have it loop around back to 0 without us having to have all
the other if statements involved. This is a nice little piece of math that you
should put in your code. Your employer will be impressed by it. Now if you
followed all the code, you should see something like this running around on the
screen. If you'll notice, something of this doesn't exactly look right. You
actually get each of the frames drawn over each other, creating this sort of
halo effect. There's a reason for this. It's worth noting that the canvas
doesn't actually clear itself each frame. Instead it allows you to just keep
piling pixels on it as you go. In order to get rid of that ghosting effect, you
have to put this line that we've conveniently left out of our previous function
back in, and that is context.clearRect. What this will do is actually clear all
of the pixels to some default value allowing us to draw back on top of it. So
you won't get the previous images actually drawn on top of each other. The
result is a nice, nifty walking robot running around on your screen, just like
it should. The result with clearRect is this nice, fancy walking robot.